ned have you ever made me cry
many times yeah do you remember when i
don't know i remember i remember
i remember some of them yeah uh one of
them was
but okay see i'll tell you one of them
and i'll tell you where it came from
okay i like it came from
things things that scare you in life
things that cause trauma or things that
cause trauma that still cause trauma in
your life today
yeah you gotta overcome them i know i
have a trauma therapist
you got but that's what i'm saying i was
trying to help you with that no it
didn't work
how i did it yeah do you know what i'm
saying yeah probably
not the correct do or whatever but yeah
but that's
also the relationship we had because we
[ __ ] with each other all the time
like that was such a such a thing i mean
you like [ __ ] with us and people i
never [ __ ] with you yeah you did
in a good way it'll get yeah a positive
way yeah but we [ __ ] with each other so
much dude that you would make fun of our
friend
that we call big john who's literally
weighs 350 [ __ ] pounds he's not fat
and he's six
foot six and this dude is looking right
at him saying some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to him
and that's who he is everybody love
doing that [ __ ] i don't remember
you don't remember i remember why do you
think you ended up first of all i know
you remember cause that's why you ended
up in that big-ass closet
[Laughter]
you don't remember well that's something
you tell the story like i just threw you
in the middle
was it you [ __ ] [ __ ] no you put me
in the closet because you came and said
i can't sleep with that [ __ ] i
cannot sleep with that [ __ ]
he snores like a goddamn and then you
went like this you put your hands right
here and you went this is him
and so i called him there were no more
rooms and we had a closet that was
literally half the size of this room
yeah it was a huge closet yeah it wasn't
like some little towel closet
it was huge and i go i make it seem like
when stories i make a scene like it's a
small club like a harry potter club yeah
like a hairy guy like hundreds of stairs
that's the way he presented that no dude
it was a
huge walk-in closet bro wow it was a
huge
walk-in closet that was literally
literally half the size of this room
and it we were able to even put a uh
like a little mattress in there
there was a mattress because that's how
he told it
we ordered a bed we ordered a bed but we
couldn't fit the bed in there
we put the mattress he made it seem like
he had to sleep standing up
[ __ ] and it was because
he didn't want to sleep with the
roommate and we tried to turn things
around
i didn't know i thought that your other
dudes were dicks i didn't think that
they ran out of rooms in the hotel i
thought you were just doing it
no punish me no why would i no
see that wouldn't be something i would
punish you for yeah
right right what i punished you for was
when i punished you i tried to help you
get over the fact that
you hated golf and you hated yourself
and your dad used to beat the [ __ ] out
that's another guy
maybe remember you made me so i mean
you're crying that one you made me cry
more time
you made me wake up play golf and to
play golf
but it wasn't for me it was to try to
first of all it was to try to get you
out
to do what we why we played golf and it
wasn't because of golf
it was to get out and do something you
already knew that i was beaten by with
golf clubs
yeah but i wanted us to have fun and
make fun of each other and for you to
make fun of bert or for you to make fun
of me or
to make fun of whoever and go like dude
you play golf we're going to shout with
that like i wanted you to be
that guy yeah yeah and in that scenario
but the whole time you were just like
can we go we're on the [ __ ] second
hope
yeah yeah yeah i would literally cry we
go please
yeah yeah yeah but let's get something
straight trembling i did
it right yeah
to to try not to [ __ ] demean him but
literally to try to help him get over
yeah not even that i was trying to get
him to have fun
in a different way in in a setting that
he looked at so that he could relate it
to something fun
yeah right that that's where i was
coming from his whole thing back in
those days was
that's part of the reason why i i was
enamored with him because the first time
i ever saw him perform i said hey man
where the [ __ ] is his next comic and
they're like we can't we don't know
so i go into the bathroom and the
bathroom inside the comedy store
in la jolla is literally a tiny stall
yeah
and a little urinal so if you're doing
something in there even if you're doing
a
toot you could hear it and i hear that's
all i hear
and i'm just gonna okay